Hi all.
My name's Adam Haar Horowitz.
I'm a PhD student in the Media
Lab in the fluid interfaces
group.
And I'm really
happy to be joined
by Agnieszka Kurant for
casts three questions series.
And we're going to be speaking
through a couple of projects
that I Agnieszka did in her
visiting artist residency
and one that we did together.
Agnieszka, do you want to start
just by introducing yourself
to people?
Hello everyone, and
thank you so much
to Cast for hosting this talk.
My name is Agnieszka Kurant.
I'm a visual artist.
And I was a visiting artist
at MIT Cast from 2016 to 2018.
Agnieszka, I know that in past
works like production line
or the end of the
signature for you,
automation, collective
intelligence,
and shared authorship have
been big themes in your work.
And so I just thought
we could start
with how those were
points of departure
for your collaboration
with Boris Katz
and that info group at MIT.
During my residency at
MIT, I was collaborating
with the CSAIL and artificial
intelligence lab of Boris Katz.
And we were working together
with Boris' fantastic
PhD and postdoc students,
Andrei Barbu and David Mayo,
on a project that
stemmed from my earlier
research and projects
that I've done before.
So I would like to share
with you a couple of images.
So I've been interested
in the phenomenon
of collective
intelligence that can
be perceived in both nature and
culture for a very long time.
And this, for example,
is one of my projects
where I outsource or
crowdsource my artworks
to colonies of living termites.
And together with entomologists
from University of Florida,
we gave termite
colonies very vividly
colored sands, gold,
and broken crystals.
And each colony built
one of these mounds.
So this here what you
can see is a series
of works called the
end of signature,
where I collect signatures
of thousands of people
of various communities of social
movements of people supporting
one cause, such
as against climate
change, and different
kind of activist groups,
but also members of
the worker's unions.
And in this series I work each
time with a computer scientist
or programmer to kind of morph--
aggregate together thousands
of these signatures
and create one single
collective signature
that represents kind of
collective personality
of a given community.
This is a facade of
the Guggenheim Museum
where we collected
signatures of the visitors.
This is on the facade of
the Cleveland Museum of Art,
where these are
all the workers--
all the employees
of this museum.
That's contract workers from
the members of the board
to the guards and
the cleaning ladies.
This is a collective
signature of all the people
living in this group of
buildings in this council
project.
The themes with the end of--
signature end production line
in terms of hybrid authorship
and hybrid production
and materialization of a
collective intelligence--
I think it's a good segue into
the animal internet project,
if you could take
people there, perhaps.
Yes, absolutely.
This is the image from,
like, a work in progress
of the project done
at Boris Katz's
lab with his PhD and
postdoc students.
So it was Boris who
collected thousands
of self portraits taken by
workers on Amazon Mechanical
Turk.
And we created a program that
aggregated all these portraits,
one line of pixels
from each photograph
to create this composite,
collective portrait
of this new working class.
Then we created
the 3D sculptures
that were a 3D cut resin
with copper and nickel plated
that were these kind
of collective portraits
of these working class.
This was a point of departure
for our project for animal
internet.
Animal internet, it was based
on my interest in how today
social energies and society are
being mined in a similar way
to oil and gas, how
expressions of our joy,
anger, frustration, and
enthusiam, happiness,
are constantly being monitored
by corporations and harvested.
And how can we ourselves
take advantage of this--
of our own social
capital and maybe
use it for other
type of projects?
So I looked at this phenomenon
called animal internet that
was described very interestingly
in a book by Alexander Pschera
about three years ago, a
book of the same title.
And he described
this phenomenon where
people start perceiving nature
and start being with nature
in various different ways.
For example, there are
animals that have chips
under their skin and they are
being tracked on animal tracker
apps around the world.
There's about 150,000
of these animals.
And at the same time, a lot
of scientific institutes
install web cams and
jungles, or in the North
Pole to watch completely wild
and completely unaware animals.
And these broadcasts are being
transmitted online and people
start following these animals.
These animals are being given
Facebook pages, fan pages,
names.
So there's this kind
of hybrid situation
of these animals being
completely wild and unaware.
And meanwhile, they
become celebrities online
and people follow that.
So our project was Adam and
our other collaborators.
We used broadcasts from two
webcams, two real webcams,
that you can see here.
One is polar bear
in the North Pole
and one is a wild tiger
in a jungle in Thailand.
And we juxtaposed
these two broadcasts
with two other broadcasts
that we created from scratch
with our group of
artists and engineers.
And so we basically created two
fictional animatronic animals.
One is an animal in
the upper left corner.
You can see an image of
kind of furry animal,
just wanted to say that we
didn't-- that all the fur used
in this project was artificial.
No animals were harmed.
So we used this
artificial fur to hide
an animatronic mechanism.
And we included real plants
and stones and fragments
of wood in, like, a terrarium.
This animal, this
artificial animal, was--
its movements were
powered by inputs
from thousands of people who
were sending us information
on Amazon Mechanical
Turk about how
they feel at any given moment.
These were aggregated, and
Adam will tell a bit more
in a couple of minutes about the
technical side of this project.
But just to mention the other
bottom right corner, camera,
this broadcast was
from the webcam
that we also kind of built from
scratch in another terrarium.
And these are robotic,
animatronic gerbils.
And this swarm of gerbles was
kind of-- their movement was
powered by, well, a program
that was parsing Twitter feeds
for protest--
of members of protest
movements around the world.
And this was then analyzed in an
artificial society model, which
is an animation model of an
artificial, fictional society
that our fantastic
engineers wrote.
And so basically,
these for cameras
were juxtaposing real animals
and artificial animals into one
broadcast where--
for the people who watched
these animals online,
it doesn't really matter
whether the real designated
nature of the real animals
exist, because anyway,
they only see their images.
And I will maybe
let Adam say more
about the technical
side of this project.
That was a content-loaded
and awesome summary.
One piece that's fun for viewers
is how we created the project,
because you initially approached
us to collaborate as part
of the signature hack-in
[? Hacking Earth. ?]
So the largest part
of this project
was done in 24 hours, where you
stayed up with us until 3:00 AM
and where we created the robotic
movements by stripping apart
a bunch of robots and creating
our own strange hybrid organism
from multiple
mechanical animals.
And then also where Agnes coded
up a sugarscape model and then
Ishan was scraping the
emotion using natural language
processing from Twitter to
see the intensity of emotion
related to tweets that had
the word protest in them.
And that was then driving the
gerbil movement, and where
then Owen was connecting with
Tim many different hex bugs
so we could make
gerbils, which could
communicate with each other
using radio frequency.
And the whole time one thing
that was really fun for me
is the discussions that we were
having were always tied back
to neuroscience, tied back
to the idea of how humans are
a hybrid organism, both in
terms of being cyborg hybrids
and then also being
hybrids in terms
of our collective intelligence
on the internet changing
our own self reflection.
And so one really fun
thing is the production
happening in such a hurry.
And the other, I think,
is all of the resonance
and themes between the
neuroscientific aspect of it
and the human computer
interaction aspect of it,
and that tying into
the themes that you're
speaking about in terms
of hybrid and collective
intelligence.
And for me, also, the
work has really continued.
We were speaking about
this just a few days ago,
but I'm starting a new project
with the support of CAST
and [? Chem ?] at
MIT where, again,
working with deconstructing
robotic animals
and reconstructing them and
connecting them to humans
so that they can materialize
different sorts of changes
in cognition.
And right now the project
that I'm working on
is a dream-activated
animals project,
where we tie a sleep sensor to
somebody, leave them in a room,
but it's full of robotic
animals that we've created.
And when that person
enters a dream state, when
they experience this
sea change in cognition,
all those animals will
wake up and start walking.
So their life only comes at the
onset of your unconsciousness.
But it's really a
tie between that idea
of how is it that we materialize
and mechanize and create
these hybrid human
robot organisms
and how is it that we can show
this energy in active form?
And it was a real
continuation of this project.
And so I was just
wondering also how
maybe the sugarscape
model that we built
or maybe the actual collective
mechanical hybrids, how
any of those themes
have continued
in your work going forward,
if any are still around?
This is absolutely fascinating,
what you said, Adam.
And I do believe that we will
continue working together
very soon.
Yeah.
And so yes, I mean, there
is not enough time here
to explain all the
implications for this project.
But of course, this hybrid
situations of, like,
nature, culture overlap.
And basically
the-- also the idea
of the collapse of
the concept of self,
I mean, the self as we knew
it no longer exists because it
turns out that the
self is a polyphony,
is an aggregate of
various kinds of agencies,
from microbial to
algorithmic to the kind
of collective intelligence as
humans being part of society.
So all this has continued
to inform my practice.
And I want to just
briefly show you, too,
two works that I've recently--
I love this.
--completed.
One of them is, I think,
particularly interesting
because of what has happened
in the world since our project
together, especially what's
happened in the world
the past couple of weeks.
So this project is called
collective Rorschach test.
This is lenticular print.
So here you can see
three different views
of the same print.
What it depicts is three
snapshots from, let's say,
a life of this
collective organism that
was created on the
platform Reddit
as part of this
social experiment
called Place, which took place
soon after our experiment
with Adam and others.
And so basically,
this experiment
consisted in over one
million people who were--
whoever wanted to
join Reddit platform
at this moment and
this project, they
could put a single pixel in a
chosen color on a white canvas.
So you can actually see the
white in the background.
And people started collaborating
and using various channels
to collaborate on various
collectively built forms,
from portraits of politicians
that you can see here,
from flags and, like, the
European Union flag, Puerto
Rican flag, and so on.
Artworks-- here we can see a
very small fragment on the Mona
Lisa--
to various kind of slogans of
protest movements and so on.
And at some point, a very
interesting form emerged.
This form was later
named the black void.
And this is this black
kind of-- and this form
changed over time.
And you can see here
how it's evolving.
And it looks like a
slime mold or a virus
or another kind of
collective organism.
And of course, today with
what's happening in the world,
and when we're looking
at the pandemic
and how people around
the world are trying
to define what this pandemic
is, what this virus is, it
itself becomes a kind of
collective Rorschach test
where everybody recognizes
something else in it.
And it collectively--
it constantly evolves.
This is the second
very big project
that I've been recently
developing and presenting.
And I will say only a
few words very briefly.
This series of works
is called conversions.
And it's directly connected
to the experiments
that we have been
doing with Adam.
And I continued working with
Agnes Cameron on this project.
So these are paintings.
They are liquid
crystal paintings.
So they are executed
on a copper plate
with paint that contains
particles of liquid crystals.
And these paintings
are AI paintings.
They are powered by the changes
in the artificial society
model.
And these models, like in the
experiments we did together,
are based on constant parsing of
the protest movements' Twitter
feeds, members of the protest
movements' Twitter feeds.
And these changes
cause differences
in artificial society model.
And this, in turn,
causes the delivery
of various electrical charges
and temperature changes
to the back of this painting.
So this is how the
painting changes over time.
You can see how it's just a few
minutes later and a few minutes
later.
And so it oscillates between
a map, a colony of bacteria,
geology, a slime mold.
And it perpetually evolves.
So these are paintings
that, like my earlier works,
are collectively authored.
So the authorship is obviously
hybridized and complex.
But also, they are, in a
way, mining social energies.
And they always evolve.
They are like living organisms.
And last but not least, I
wanted to mention something
very important
for both the works
that we did with Boris
Katz and his students,
and also for these
works, and which
remains a very important
issue for me, is
that the proceeds from
the sales of these works,
if they ever get sold,
is always redistributed.
In the case of the works
that you are now looking at,
the conversions, I give back
a portion of the profits
to the protest movements.
In the case of the works
that we did with Boris Katz,
the proceeds from these
works are redistributed even
among the workers
of Amazon Mechanical
Turk that participated in it.
And so I'm interested in
continuing the exploration
of redistribution, how
redistribution of capital
can be explored with
artificial intelligence
and how we can today
think about the crossover
of collective intelligence
and artificial intelligence
in the arts.
Cool.
I think that it's almost
time for us to sign off.
But I just wanted to say that I
think the project and speaking
with you, Agnieszka, for me was
a real onset of using hybrids
outside to think
about hybrids inside.
I'm so excited about
the idea that we
are many more intelligences
than we give us
credit for ourselves.
And we can think about that
in terms of the gut brain
or we can think
about that in terms
of the intelligence
in our left foot
or we can think
about that in terms
of biological neural networks.
But this idea of your work
showing these outside hybrids
taking us and putting us in
touch with our hybrids inside,
and also how that
demands that we then
think about collective
authorship and redistribution
of benefits from what it is that
we make as hybrid organisms.
But I think it's
time to sign off.
I just want to give a big thank
you to CAST for this series,
but also for the
opportunity to collaborate
with Agnieszka, which has been
awesome, and will continue.
And that's about it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you-- thank you.
I would like to give
my special thank you
to Leila Kinney, who
was the person who
invited me first to join CAST.
Thank you Katherine Higgins.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, Adam.
It was a pleasure.
Right on.
Thanks, y'all.
Be well.
Thank you all for joining
us for this conversation
with Agnieszka Kurant
and Adam Haar Horowitz.
Please join us next week for
three questions with Karim Ben
Khelifa and Danielle Olson.
And visit arts.mit.edu
from anywhere
for a wide range of arts
activities, online exhibitions
and performances,
research, and more.
Have a great weekend, everyone.
Bye.
Have a great weekend.
Adios, y'all.